did you ever kill anybody
not intentionally but yeah
that's a lie
but it's no lie chatty data may just be
vanity Fair's sexiest cover ever
[Music]
the February issue on newsstands January
24th has the Magic Mike star opening up
about meeting girlfriend Zoe Kravitz
during production of her film P Island
quote she had passion in there and she
had a point of view that was really
specific to who she was and what her
experience was and from one beautiful
lady to another Jennifer Lopez am I a
better stripper than her
I'm gonna say yeah I would go harder if
I was stripping against her I'm just
saying I'm gonna I'm gonna take it to
JLo's front door
he's telling the truth yeah
also revealing the truth about whether
he thinks he's hotter than Brad Pitt
himself
absolutely not
no unfortunately no like I had I don't
think really anybody I mean he's more
handsome than George sorry George but
that's just the fact that I think most
people would agree and get this there
was some beef between his daughter and
Sandra Bullock's daughter in the
schoolyard
our daughters got into a couple scraps
at school because they're both very very
strong-willed uh little girls and yeah
it was uh it was fun it was a very fun
year that year they love each other now
um literally can't like get enough of
each other they just want to hang out
all the time now
telling the truth
[Music]